vas-y la vérité vas-y je veux parler à
cœur ouvert
je m'appelle Quentin j'ai tant Alberto
j'ai 27 ans je suis passionné de cinéma
je suis réalisateur je réalise des
courts métrages aujourd'hui bah je
réalise mon cinquième court-métrage qui
s'appelle mieux à tabacounda c'est une
bande d'amis qui se retrouve dans un
Airbnb alors d'un weekend décide de
faire un jeu de loup-garou et la
particularité de ce qu'on mettra c'est
lorsque le village s'endorment on se
retrouve dans un village au Sénégal qui
s'appelle tabacounda actuellement on est
à 3 jours de tournage dans dans la ferme
de de pontarly à Bailly en 3 jours de
nuit c'est à dire on a des horaires
assez drastiques parce qu'on tourne de
23h à 6h du matin pour avoir toutes les
deux belles de belles images et par la
suite on ira au Sénégal pour faire les
dernières parties du jeu aujourd'hui on
a accompagné de on a très acteurs sur ce
projet donc c'est un gros jeu c'est une
grosse pression mais les acteurs sont
très bons
on va envoyer du lourd OK et voilà non
c'est trop cool
[Musique]
je suis accompagné par alta media
production qui est par cette photo ça
fait maintenant deux ans que cette
production me suit elle sent aujourd'hui
dans la production et ont été fascinés
par mes projets que j'ai réalisé
auparavant comme corniches de nous qui a
été mon dernier court-métrage qui a été
primé en Suède à Londres et en Suisse ça
parlait de des femmes transgenres
tu savais que j'étais née de sexe
masculin
je comprends pas trop là
j'ai commencé ma transition ici 7 ans je
suis une femme trans
pourquoi tu me l'as pas dit plus tôt
il est très dur parce que il faut avoir
de l'inspiration faut être patient on se
prend énormément de portes on n'a pas de
revenus stable parce que lorsqu'on n'est
pas appelé bah on n'a pas de source de
revenus tout simplement bon pour ça que
j'ai une stabilité à côté ou je suis
commercial mais il faut être passionné
pour moi le cinéma il faut être
passionné si on n'est pas passionné ça
fonctionne pas moi j'ai commencé à en
autodidacte avec des courts métrages
j'ai monté une boîte de froid qui
s'appelle wild film par la suite j'ai
fait plusieurs pubs et j'ai atterri
l'école court trajet mais en 2019 après
une formation trois mois j'ai décidé de
de lancer tout simplement ma première
raison était sur Amal parler d'une femme
voilée qui a qui trouvait qu'il ne
trouvait pas de boulot après son retour
à Londres
je sais voir quand ça va pas
travailler au salon
kit elle va faire son master à post
jungle colonial
et là tu viens tu veux bosser dans mon
salon tu crois que j'ai chaud
c'est sur les hommes battus donc